think promiscuity is painting us
especially like now like you know you're
a similar age to me like we've been on
social media I don't know about you but
like I think I got Snapchat when I was
like 13. yeah so it's like I know like
before you had like page three and
things like that but like I just feel
like things have changed and like now
you'll see like 10 year old kids who are
like like they'll just see these like
only fans models or whatever like and
it's just so like they don't even blink
like it's just so like everyone's just
used to it I've been Tick Tock as well
even like Tick Tock you have like 14
year olds looking like they're 18 like
you know moving their waist around it's
like like it's really scary I've seen it
it's really scary and I just don't think
it's gonna do anyone any help in the
long run men or women like it's it's
tainting everyone's view of everything
in my opinion